well remember the UK was not part of the
euro and and what I argue here is the
euro was really flawed from birth it
wasn't a question of policy decisions it
was the structure of the eurozone itself
but one of the things that's been
exhibited in the euro in the management
of the crises one after another is a
kind of rigidity that I think turned off
a lot of people in the UK it was a the
way the policy evolved with Germany
dominating the discussions country
voting over and over again we want to
move away from austerity toward growth
strategy and Germany's response is we
don't care how your citizens voted even
if it's 60 some percent you're going to
take our medicine even if you and most
of their economics profession in the
world thinks it's wrong medicine so
there's any time across a very
anti-democratic and I think that spirit
that rigidity almost surely played a
role you were better judge of that than
I but played a role in the in in the
brexit referendum and you you talked you
talked a little bit before about the
fact that if for instance there's TTIP
this new trade deal that's been proposed
between the EU and the US if that was in
there then the UK would be better off
outside if that's still the case because
I mean like a lot of people think that
TTIP may not happen anymore
so do you really think that the UK would
actually be better off outside the EU as
things currently stand well you know you
can't answer the question whether it's
better off or worse off because you
don't know what kind of deal that you
are going to be able to reach with the
EU and there's a inherent uncertainty in
that it's not even clear what your
government wants not clear what the EU's
response certainly clear the markets do
not think that it's going to be disaster
the markets have not gone down I think
among many economists the real worry is
not the short run the media
jerm and among what my concern was a
little bit the politics they momentum
that this would give to the
disintegration of Europe the reversal of
of a century of European integration
century and a half and moving away and
accept political consequence that may be
really far more important than the
economic a lot of people are looking at
the economic numbers that we have now
and consumer confidence doesn't look
like it's too bad house prices don't
look like they've come down all that
much as if yet GDP looks okay for the
time being and are saying to themselves
was there just a lot of scare mongering
might things be okay in fact might we
actually be able to be better off
outside than in well they were clear
were some scare mongering but remember
there was a lot of uncertainty and a lot
of economists always have in their mind
the worst-case scenario and they're
saying you're taking a big risk you
haven't seen the big benefit you took
risk the fact that the delivers my
payoff I mean it in the payoff and you
haven't seen the benefits you haven't
seen the cost and that's why I said
before to me much more important are
these medium-term issues and the
political dynamics to which it is good
could lead you have been an advisor to
Jeremy Corbyn and John McDonald a young
Labor Party and the Labour Party are you
currently advising them whether the
Council of Economic Advisers the concert
that they was was an advisory to the
Labor Party now to the individuals and
as you know there's been some turmoil in
the Labor Party about the leadership and
until that kicks decided it's very
difficult to talk about what sort of
action yeah but do you think that Jeremy
Corbyn is the right man to lead the
Labour Party well what I think is very
strongly is the Labour Party needs to go
in a progressive direction that the
direction to which had been pulled by
Tony Blair was the wrong direction
that it didn't represent you know it may
have been right for that moment but just
like in the United States there's a
recognition that the policies that we
undertook in the 90s the financial
sector deregulation the unfettered
globalization we're wrong and the way we
did it didn't protect a lot of ordinary
citizens the way we did it didn't even
protect the economy we have the data now
we didn't have that that show with that
for instance in the United States the
bottom 90% have had stagnant income
basically over the last third of a
century that's the failed economy and
all the benefits have grown gone to the
top 10% that kind of neoliberalism
neoclassical and the policies are flawed
or flawed and so it seems absolutely
imperative on both sides that land aid
for us to explore alternatives to that
vision and what has me so excited is
that on both sides Atlantic young people
share that vision that I have is a
little bit older is it but specifically
you know we've we've had some time to
test by the Jeremy Corbyn is kind of
capable of taking the labour party in
that direction so I suppose there is
that question mark whether he is the
right person specifically yeah that's
the internal politics of my opinion
about that I only see it from afar and
just by having advised the Labour Party
this might be a kind of place then I'd
rather not I'd rather I cam it because I
don't you know you know when I talk to
him he seems reasonable and and
intelligent and and open but he's
clearly had probable bring along some of
the parliamentary parties as finally
obviously we have the u.s. presidential
election this year some people might be
looking towards the u.s. seeing what's
happened in the UK with brexit and feel
that there might be a similar upsurge in
the US and
that could help Donald Trump is that
something that you see is a risk well
what is very clear is that some of that
dissatisfaction with globalization with
a lack of trust in the establishment the
realization that after the 2008 crisis
the government came to the rescue of the
banks but not of ordinary citizens all
that is playing out on both sides of the
Atlantic and helped Trump get the
Republican nomination Professor Joseph
Stiglitz thanks very much for joining us
to be here thank you